- Hey, we're the cast of One Piece.
- We had so much fun
shooting this show together.
Now we're about to show
you some personal photos
from production that
we have on our phones.
- What's on my phone?
(cast gasping)
- Is that?
- That's Peter.
- [Emily] Both of y'all's
teeth are so white.
- Oh,
that's mine.
Emily, actually, you gave this to me.
- You were like, just
so effortlessly cool.
I was like, "Oh, can I
please take a picture?
Is this okay?"
And then you were like.
- And then Iñaki comes right next to me.
- Yeah.
(cast cheering)
- Oh the COVID mask.
- We shot during COVID
so we had to wear these masks every day.
We were the only ones
that you got the mask
where you could see their faces,
so I started drawing little mustaches.
(cast gasping)
- That day was the first day
I had to do any stunts on the show,
and I remember I was so
preoccupied with going,
it was full of SAs on both floors,
and everyone was looking
down as it was happening.
I just remember thinking, "If you slip
and fall on your ass right now."
- Oh, look at that picture.
Remember that day Mackenyu?
- Yeah.
Cape Town.
Right?
- I remember we went to
have some lunch or dinner
or something like that, and
then we took that picture.
I was so excited.
The fans were waiting
for that picture, huh?
- I know, they were all like, "Oh my God.
They found Zoro.
They found Zoro!"
- Ooh.
- Oh my God.
Okay, so I started doing,
it started with Iñaki
where he would take naps
in the morning in the makeup chair,
and so I would take selfies
while he was sleeping,
and he found out, he has some of me,
and then Langley, who
plays Axe-Hand Morgan
ended up falling asleep and so we.
- Got 'em!
(cast chanting "got 'em")
- Oh, are you kidding me?
There it is!
- Oh!
I remember that day.
I had to film this underwater scene,
and Taz just out of sympathy,
just decided to jump into water,
even though he didn't have
to just to bring me company.
Like that's just the kind
of guy he is, you know?
- Such a Taz-y move.
- Thank you all so much for watching
and check out One Piece only on Netflix.